[Applause]
sheikh sharif ahmed was president of
somalia once before and he wants to be
president again
his government was credited with
developing somalia's constitution and
building the national army after the
central government collapsed in 1991
it was criticized for corruption
i want to build a government that gives
equal rights to all the somali people
and provides security and justice to the
somali people
he's more known for trying to include
all political factions than for specific
policies
sheikh sharif is widely seen as one of
the strongest contenders he's one of 39
candidates who have registered their
posters line this street in mogadishu
one of them will go on to lead a
government that doesn't control much of
somalia beyond here the capital sways of
the countryside are controlled by the
armed group al-shabab somalis don't even
get to vote in this election it's
members of parliament who will elect the
president and the members of parliament
were selected by clan representatives
everyone familiar with the process say
it's been marred by vote buying and
corruption
another former president hassan sheikh
muhammad was in the running and also
widely seen as a possible winner
when he was in office un investigators
said private individuals embezzled vast
sums of money from the central bank
once a peace activist he's known as a
negotiator and says he'll mend the rifts
between somalia's federal state
incumbent president mohammed abdullahi
farmer is running again
he's lost support in parliament his
opponents say he's divisive made
somalia's armed conflicts worse and
brought economic decline
he's promising change
hassan ali khairi was prime minister
under farmer until they fell out he's
also a prominent contender
the final outcome of the vote depends on
who ends up supporting who
it's very difficult to predict
you know potential alliances at this
stage i think a lot of back room deals
and under the table deals are happening
as we speak and they'll continue to
happen until the 11th hour
just before dawn on sunday morning
they'll continue to make deals
members of parliament will vote on
sunday in a series of up to three rounds
in the safety of mogadishu's green zone
far removed from most somalis
the region's worst drought in decades is
just one of the many challenges faced by
millions of people and by somalia's next
leader
malcolm webb al jazeera mogadishu
somalia